dans le projet de paris saclay on a une
équipe qui s'appelle la direction de
l'aménagement avec notre mission c'est
de préparer les terrains qui seront
donnés à construire aux différents
promoteurs constructeurs des écoles ou
des bus des bureaux des logements et
donc nous ont fait tout ce qu'ils sont
les rues les boulevards les espaces
publics les places les jardins tout ce
qui va permettre d'amener le transport
les réseaux donc alors on fait souvent
ce qu'on appelle un peu le sol de la vie
c'est une opération qui couvre un
territoire très très grand kiff
représente plus de 7000 700 hectares et
qui s'étend sur une quinzaine de
kilomètres de versailles jusqu'à massy
jusqu'à un paléo et après avec à
l'intérieur des espaces de développement
dans lequel on va aménager des
différents quartiers
en effet il y à des ensembles
considérables comme le ceva qui sont là
depuis des dizaines d'années donc il
s'agit d'une transformation et pas d'une
création ex nihilo
et ça c'est très important c'est qu'on
s'accroche un contexte à des présences à
des prêts existence à des usages et des
habitants d'une culture paysagère très
forte on est tout proche de versailles
on est dans un pré de la vallée de
chevreuse d'une présence de la
géographie naturelles mais aussi de
l'histoire des boisements mais également
l'eau sont des éléments très déterminant
techniquement mais aussi dans l'ambiance
que l'on cherche à donner dans ce campus
on retrouvera aussi d une programmation
où on va avoir bien sûr des logements de
la vraie ville comme jacques verdier
avec des commerces des écoles dont quand
même une dimension d'éducation
d'enseignement supérieur très forte des
burons qui sont pas des bureaux
banalisée mais des locaux de recherche
de pour des start up donc on a une
programmation très particulière à mettre
cette dimension du coût d'un public
jeune étranger des gens qui vont de
manière temporaire qui vont habiter là
quelques mois quelques années
c'est un ensemble qui se tissent et qui
donne la structure qui permet de
s'orienter facilement et donner de la
qualité aux transports quand on se
déplace ça doit être agréable on doit se
trouver dans un paysage internet
on a ce rêve que l'arrivée à saclay
horribles sur le plateau justement on
sera dans un paysage et et que ce campus
apparaîtra comme une sorte de très
grands parcs c'est une des ambitions